-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
"If I Had a Superpower" tweets
from you guys.
Here we go. This first one
is from @haylsann11.
She says...
[ Laughter, applause ]
That's fantastic.
-Oh!
Three-foot hoagie.
-Oh, you got
a three-foot hoagie, dude.
[ Laughs ]
Yeah. Invite you to parties
and stuff.
That'd be awesome.
-Me and my three-foot hoagies.
-If we slap hands and pull back,
it's a party sub?
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @aking443
He says...
[ Laughter ]
It's like...
[ Applause ]
This one's from @CNHolmberg.
He says...
[ Applause ]
I can't do that.
-Open the door.
-What's that -- the tube?
-Oh, the pneumatic tube
at the banks? Yeah.
-Yeah, that's good technology.
-Those were back in the day.
That was great.
[ Laughter ]
-That's the future, man.
Phbt -- Everybody's
gonna go by tube.
-[ Laughs ] Vrmm.
[ Laughter ]
We'll travel through tubes, man.
Yeah.
-[ Gags ]
-This one's from @PhishAndFish,
but the first "fish"
is spelled with a "ph."
-Ooh, like the band.
Like the jam band.
-Yeah, Phish.
She says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
There we go.
-Wow.
-That is -- That's a superpower.
-Fantastic.
-[ Laughs ]
-Doesn't wanna know the ending.
Just wants to know
if she's satisfied.
-This one's from @BridgePidge22.
-BridgePidge22
-She says...
[ Applause ]
Ahh. Boop.
-Perfect.
-This one's from @GeorgeDarkow.
He says...
[ Applause ]
-Nope!
Flip it.
-Flip it.
-And reverse it.
This one's from @jamiewboggs.
He says...
And there you go. Those are
"The Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out more
of our favorites, go to...